Good morning, everybody. I'm really happy to chair this
important and interesting session.
So
can you--
I'm Sun Young Ra, the medical oncologist from Yonsei Cancer Center, South Korea,
and it's really my honor
to chair with our good friends.
So as you know,
peritoneal metastasis has a very poor prognosis
regardless of the tumor types. And recently we have more and
more incidents of gastric cancer with peritoneal metastasis, but
also other tumor types. So we made this
session specific for the understanding of peritoneal metastasis and how we
can tactic those tumors. So,
the first one is about the gastric cancer with the peritoneal metastasis, will be
presented by myself. And then Dr. Raghav Sundar from Yale
University will share the recent updates about the
molecular heterogeneity in colorectal peritoneal metastasis.
And then,
Dr. Ignacio Garcia from MGH will
present the mutation signature and cellular phenotypes in ovarian peritoneal
metastasis. So throughout these different tumors with the peritoneal
metastasis, even it has a similar
soil of a peritoneum, it has a different seed. So you can see the difference.
I think it's a good point to compare those
three different tumor types. Okay, so I will start the
presentation of
multimodal treatment strategies for the gastric cancer peritoneal metastasis,
and I have more of an understanding of spatial niche and tumor
microenvironment in the GCPM.
So for the advanced gastric cancer, it's important to understand the
pattern of metastasis. So the most common, and
we can think about the structure, the direct invasion and
intraperitoneal spread is the important pattern.
So after the tumor cells are crossing the serosa, it just go down to
that peritoneal lesion. So direct invasion and the peritoneal metastasis
is most common. And then hematogenous
metastasis and liver, bone, lung, brain.
In this order, there are common hematogenous metastasis in the
gastric cancer. And recently, as we have more screening
tool, we have more and more bone metastasis of gastric cancer.
And then lymphatic metastasis, so only through that lymphatic
pathway, para-aortic lymph nodes or the left supraclavicular lymph nodes are very
important, the area of
metastasis. So the GCPM has
histology features associated with a diffuse-type gastric cancer, and
the cell type is mostly poorly cohesive carcinoma or signet ring
cell carcinoma, and has a diffuse
infiltrative growth pattern. And also in the peritoneal metastasis, they have
a dense stroma fibrosis and extremely poor vasculature,
and also that makes a immunosuppressive environment.
So these are what we understand, and now we have more and
more data really supporting it happens in the
real tissues and the cells in that area.
So we are saying poor prognosis of peritoneal metastasis.
Why? Because the first one is poor performance.
If the disease are in the peritoneum, they cannot eat, they cannot
digest. All those have a poor performance and makes it difficult to
continue the treatment. And in the gastric cancer with the peritoneal
metastasis, currently, systemic treatment is the only
treatment with the various agents.
And there are some issues of these patient population, because in
the clinical trials, sometimes we exclude these patients because
of the non-measurable disease or massive ascites with a poor
performance. So we cannot analyze all those
proper efficacy of those agents in that patient
population. And also it's difficult quantitation and diagnosis and the
treatment response in this group of the patients.
And also we don't have, until now, no
site-specific drug regimens. So we need to understand the
biology properly and then develop really targeting those
drugs. And the
several reasons for the limited efficacy of systemic therapy.
One is a peritoneum plasma barrier, limited vascularity of many tumor
deposits, and the immune-privileged niche.
So that is a reason why we are thinking of an intraperitoneal treatment.
In the gastric cancer, it's not standard yet, and the role of
conversion surgeries are coming up, and then, yeah, again, we need the novel
agents. I will start with our real-world data,
to understand about the epidemiology of these patients.
So from 2015 to 2025, about
3,200 cases of stage
four gastric cancer patients are there, and at any time,
peritoneal metastasis is 70.8%. So if you
see that usual
paper from Western, it's around 40 to 50.
So in the
Asian patients, we have more peritoneal metastasis.
And as you see here, patients with peritoneal metastasis has a poorer
survival, and especially inside of the subgroups,
HER2-positive is about 15%. In these HER2-positive patients,
peritoneal metastasis in any time is about half.
But in HER2 negative, you can see that the peritoneal metastasis is more higher,
75%. So in Asian patients with antrum
disease, they have more and more higher incidence of peritoneal
metastasis. And how about the overall survival based on
the different metastatic sites? Because it's not just peritoneum.
We have,
as you see that, a hematogenous and distant lymph
node metastasis. And the HER2 negative and HER2 positive has a different
outcome. So I divided this clinical outcome in the
HER2 positive and negative. The-We can see that, again,
HER2 negative has a higher peritoneal metastasis, about 75%, and
less hematogenous compared to HER2 positive.
And both groups show very good survival with
lymph node-only metastasis. It has a limited tumor burden, has a good
performance. And if we have all these triple
metastasis, the survival is really poor.
But in the peritoneal metastasis, it's similar to hematogenous
metastasis. So we can see even it's a peritoneal
metastasis, it's similar to hematogenous metastasis with
poorer survival. So, with TCGA molecular
characteristics, we know that peritoneal mets are more
enriched in the genome stable subtypes, and the EMT is
activated and the stem cell has been featured.
And these are very early bulk data.
And now we have tried to understand more about the peritoneal lesions.
But still, the metastatic cascades of these
peritoneal mets are still not enough, and it's piece by
piece. So it started from the EMT heterogeneity,
clones in the primary tumor gets the EMT and goes
to the bloodstream or the whatever, and in the end, it has
organ-specific homing and colonization.
And that's related to the seed and soil hypothesis.
So the seed from the gastric cancer lineage
needs to be adapted in this peritoneal microenvironment
properly. And during this process, a lot of different
mechanisms are coming up. So to understand, there are
many papers out there, but it's very limited again.
So one thing is technology. So DNA sequencing cannot
show the TME biology, and bulk RNA-Seq also cannot show you
the intra-tumor heterogeneity. And single-cell
transcriptomics has more information but has limited information
about the interaction on the spatial.
So now we have a spatial transcriptomics to cover
these of the questions. And this is our Yonsei Cancer
Center Translation Research Platform.
So most of the clinical samples available go to the
tumor bank with blood, and that has a tissue and blood ingest,
and if possible, we do that transcriptomics.
And if feasible, we have an organoid and PCD bank.
And then those characterizations are compared with
patients and then also useful for the drug screening.
So I will start with the DNA sequencing of the primary tumor.
So at this time, one of the problem of research difficulties
for the peritoneal mets is
we cannot have much of peritoneal metastatic tissues.
Usually, it's not available. For that, we need to do the surgery.
So
we started to check primary tumor genetic alteration based on
the DNA sequencing. Are there any differences to predict the
metastatic? So out of
633 primary tumors, as you see here, hematology,
lymph node metastasis has a similar pattern of proliferation and
oncogene activation, and the DNA repair is activated.
But in the patients with primary peritoneal mets,
this is the primary tumors, and these are
39 peritoneal mets tissues. And you can see here, some
of the tissues are showing the activation, but
mostly it's adhesion-related. And interestingly, DNA
repair is decreasing. And another thing is
the FGFR2 has been showing more amplified
in this peritoneum or the peritoneal mets patients.
So it could be one of another target for the future.
And as you heard, the DNA repair genes are more
down-regulated and related to the decreased
neoantigenesis, and that can be related to the poorer
immune surveillance in that tumor area.
Then we did about 100 cases with a primary tumor
for the bulk RNA-Seq predicting, try to figure out the predicting
markers for the peritoneal mets. And unfortunately, there is no big
difference. So this is a problem with bulk RNA-Seq.
It's a kind of a mixture. So we could see some
of the peritoneal mets showed elevated Notch, VEGF
signal, and the reduced GAS signal, but it's not that strong
to differentiate
in the primary tumors. So it's difficult to
predict what's going on in the primary tumor tissues.
And then we moved to the transcriptomics, and it's about
42 stage four gastric cancer in the
EGD biopsy primary tissues. And we can see some of the peritoneal
metastasis and the peritoneal no metastasis cases as a bit of
a different pathways are activated, but it's
still not that clear. It's vague. And one interesting
point from here, this single-cell RNA transcriptomics is a trajectory
analysis. So you can see that in the tumor epithelial
area is a kind of a fundamental lesion, and it
progress to the branch area with highly
proliferative tumor cells. And then it goes to several ways, and some
of them are going to EMT and the stem cell component.
And when we see the patients with peritoneal metastasis,
orange is the peritoneal mets. In the primary
tumors already, they have many,
the orange things, and it goes to proliferation, and it goes and
to the EMT and stem cell signature.
But when we see the lymph node-only mets or the hematogenous mets, you can see
that those specific mets clones are
orange, is smaller. But anyway, they are in the primary tumor
and go to proliferation and then did not go far to the EMT signature.
The same for the hematogenous mets.
So we can see lymphatics and the hematogenous mets are different from
peritoneal mets, and peritoneal mets definitely need these
stem cell characters and also the EMT signatures.
SoNow, we have a special transcriptomics to
understand the special landscape and cellular crosstalk.
And to be honest with you, I'm the clinician, and I'm doing some of the
translational research, but these are special, has a lot of
information which I cannot understand everything.
So it could be very superficial, but hopefully, there are my colleagues
to support me for this data analysis.
So we have matched nine patients,
stage four gastric cancer with synchronous peritoneal mets.
And all these are HER2 negative and polycohesive in the
IHC. So we have primary nine and the
peritoneum nine tissues with a special transcriptomics with the
Xenium5K and do a series of the analysis.
So starting with the single-cell landscape
to try to understand tumor microenvironment, as you see here, compared to
primary tumors in the peritoneal lesions, it has a
higher fibroblast, endothelial cells,
macrophages, and the T cells. So,
we've been thinking it could be, but these data is the same patient
simultaneous
tissue collection, and then it shows that things.
So as you see here, this is one example.
It's a primary tumor in the peritoneum.
And in the peritoneum, the blue is a CAF,
the fibroblast. So in the peritoneum, it's really, compared to
primary, there are a lot of increased fibroblasts, and
also increased number of T cells are there.
So compared to primary tumors, the peritoneal
lesions has a higher CAF with a dense
fibroblast and also the increase of blood vessels and the immune cells
are there. So this is a starting point to understand there is a
difference between primary and the mets.
And then, through that NMF pattern analysis,
we tried to understand what's the cellular
interactions. So as you see here, there are more cell-to-cell
correlation among fibroblasts and the T cells and macrophages.
So immune cells and fibroblasts are working together.
And then,
this reveals four biological signatures from
stomach to peritoneum. And as you see, these
fibroblasts are more prominent in the
peritoneal mets. So this is another example.
This is not just cell from the previous slide.
This is
the
pattern. So pattern two is more of the fibroblasts.
As you see here, compared to primary tumors, it has a
highly activated fibroblasts are there.
And also we can see so many CAF-related markers and
ECM barriers are activated in that
pattern two patients. And then because
inside of fibroblasts, there are a lot of different subgroups are there.
So we did a sub-clustering of fibroblasts population, and we
can see, compared to stomach to the peritoneum, there are
increased number of
remodeling CAF and the immune controlling CAF and the
mesothelial CAF. So these are more active
to changing the extracellular modeling.
So it's increased in the peritoneum.
But the normal stress-related CAF is relatively decreasing in the
peritoneum. So we can see that among the increased CAF,
the more active and more aggressive CAFs are increased in the peritoneum.
Then, we do this transcription enrichment analysis,
similar to DE analysis. And as you see that the peritoneum has higher
gene signature with cell matrix adhesion and the cell
substrate adhesion. So this is expected.
If the cells are going there, EMT cells
need to be settled down in that area, and these gene
expressions are supporting that information.
And interestingly, as a clinician, currently we are
having many targeted agents and also
novel drugs are in the development.
And one of that is cloudin. It's very specific to the gastric.
But in the gastric primary tumor, it has higher expression as we
expected. But as you see here, in the peritoneum, it's
really decreased the expression.
So that means anti-cloudin antibody could not work, might not
work in the peritoneal mets lesions.
Or in other words, we need to control from the primary tumor before
peritoneal mets. So it's very important.
And then, not only for that, currently we have many ADCs,
HER2, HER3, and FGF2. They have a little bit of
decrease in the peritoneum. So the drug development, we need to think
about how we can control that, not only for the primary tumor, but the
other metastatic sites. And then, as we expected,
fibroblast-related EMT novel related targets
like collagen, FAB or the EXO is increasing in the
peritoneum. So that means we have another potential target
with these peritoneal mets area. But sometimes, as
you see this patient, primary tumor and the peritoneal mets are coming
together. So we should think about how to control those both
targets. And thenThese are the cancer cells.
So these are, as you see here, primary tumor and the peritoneum.
Cancer cell distributions are different.
Some of them are similar between the two tumor area, but
some of them are more higher in the peritoneum and then more common
in the stomach area. So we can see that pattern one is more common
higher in the peritoneal cells. So these are the
patterns with that gene expression.
And
with that, we also did a trajectory analysis.
And as you see here, this is a common area.
If among them, also, the cells with the epithelial
cancer expression-related markers, it goes to the
stomach cancer area. But if they have ECM modeling
and cell migration, it goes to the pattern one, which is a
primary at the peritoneal mets area.
But more than that, we know that there are not just
the epithelia or the EMT. There is a starting
engine, which is a Yap/Taz modules are activated in the primary
tumor. So from the primary tumor, if there are some of more and
higher activated Yap/Taz, in the
end, it goes to the peritoneal lesion.
And if it goes to peritoneum, it needs to be settled down,
which is a homing signal. CXCL4 modules are more
activated in that peritoneal lesion.
So we can think about there are different,
the
clones are there in the primary tumor and the peritoneum.
And then we also evaluated the
inflammatory cells. And interestingly, compared to primary tumors,
in the peritoneum, there are more T effector cells.
So
we've been thinking always there are immune
suppressive peritoneal mets, but here the cells itself are
really highly increased. I've been saying that T cells are increased again and
again. So as you see here, the numbers are increased, but these are
the peritoneal cells, and these are the peritoneal T cells.
As you see here, T cell activation or the immune
checkpoint are higher in the stomach compared to peritoneum,
meaning peritoneum has a less activation.
And the granzyme, those are
the cytokines are not secreted, and also the other
immunosuppressive markers are not that active.
But that means T cells are there. And also you
heard that from our, in the DNA data that has a
less neoantigenicity. So what's happening?
It looks like there is a
physically shielding with the fibroblast and that
collagen, those extracellular matrix is blocking the
direct contact between tumor cells or the
immune cells. But it's a hypothesis, so we need
to think about how we can prove that.
And also think about that, that means we need to control
the CAF is really important for these type of metastasis.
And then we also do that spatial domain
NMF analysis. So it started from cell, and now it goes
to multiple growth structure. So it show that,
as you see here, compared to stomach to the peritoneum,
most of the tumor
proliferation and the metabolism are active in the peritoneal lesion, but
in the more prominent in the peritoneal lesion is
immunosuppressive environment with the CAFs.
So the data comes
consistently with the
CAFs are very active in this
environment. And also this is not just a single
cells invasion. It's a microstructure formation.
So with these cells are coming, they are making a different
structure to protect the cancer cells from the immune cells
and they block the delivery of the drug to the
tumor. So now we understand about that is really
problematic for prognosis. And this is
not just a single gene network analysis.
This is domain network, spatial domain network analysis.
So as you see here, compared to stomach, it has increased
number of very complicated network
in the peritoneal mets. So these are the stomach signaling.
These are the peritoneum signaling.
So just
briefly, dots and the colors, you can see more
peritoneum signaling. That means even in the common network,
the networking is more complex and more
diverse in the peritoneal metastasis.
And also there are some unique network.
As you know that the CXCL2 and that
CXCL4 and the
CXCL12 or whatever, those are the matrix adhesion.
Some networks are activated in this thing.
So this is a very early data, but
after I see all those data, looks like it's been
known. I know those in the theory, but now we see the
data. So I think this is a good start to understand those
peritoneal mets biology. So we have a more understandings
through these improved technology, and also it has a good understanding of
treatment resistance. But these biology really important for the future
drug development from the
primary gastric cancer. And surely, it's not just
peritoneal.
Currently, we are working with the other hematogenous metastatic sites.
Has a different biology or different
TMEs as compared to peritoneal mets.
And with that, still we need a continuous collaboration.
So these are our teams with the Yonsei Cancer Center and Songdong, and they are
Aptis and the Genios did a lot of support for that
sequencing, and the Raghav and the Joseph also support the
analysis of this. Thank you so much. I will finish here.
And if you have any questions, please
come to the microphoneAnd if you are on the online,
you can send the question to the online.
Oh, thank you so much.
Okay. So,
yeah, please.
Thank you. It's a really great talk.
Have you looked at the actual malignant ascites?
It's because a part of microenvironment-
Yeah
... also T cells,
tumor cells, especially after treatment, about tumor evolution issues,
and compare it with implants and primary tumor.
That's a good question. Actually, I've been working on the ascites
before this spatial, because these tissues are not
feasible to collect. So usually what we test is ascites,
and then PCD and organoids from that.
But you know that those are not the spatial
informations available. Those are just
cells characteristics, and it's been a bit different.
So I didn't show here, but we have ascites-derived
organoids, and those transcriptomics and proteomics
are in the way of analysis comparing with these
spatial things.
Thank you.
Okay.
If there is no more questions still, after the end, if you
have some time, we will continue to have a Q&A.
And from the online audiences, please send the questions.
So, I will introduce the next speaker, Dr. Raghav Sundar.
He's a very active translation research in the
GI field, and especially he's been interested in the peritoneal
metastasis for a long time. So, he will give us the talk
entitled "Molecular Heterogeneity in Colorectal Peritoneal Metastasis." Let's
welcome Dr. Raghav.
Thank you, Dr. Ra, for the very kind introduction, and I'd like to thank the
organizing committee for inviting me to speak at this session.
As Dr. Ra mentioned, I'm a GI oncologist and a translational physician scientist
interested in
treating patients with peritoneal metastases.
And today I'll share a little bit about
work done in the colorectal peritoneal metastasis space.
These are my disclosures.
We'll talk a little bit, I'm imagining that folks in the audience and people
listening online are going to be a mix of both clinicians as well as scientists,
and so
bear with me if I go through some basics, both from the clinical side as well as
the scientific side, and try and put
stuff together. We'll do the clinical part first, and then we'll go
into some of the translational research done in this space.
As with gastric cancer, we also know that colorectal cancer patients with
peritoneal metastases have much poorer outcomes compared to those that have
metastases to other organs. This is a little bit
different from gastric cancer, where specific,
the organotropism of gastric cancer to the peritoneum is higher
compared to colorectal cancer. A lot of times, colorectal cancer has
liver metastases compared to peritoneal metastases, but the ones that
do have peritoneal metastases, this was a paper that was published
about 10 years ago now, that showed that there was a much poorer survival
for patients with peritoneal metastases.
Almost half of what we see with lung metastases, for
example.
And despite the fact that we know that
different sites of metastases for these different tumor types actually
have different prognoses, as a medical oncologist, for the longest
of time, we always treat patients with stage four cancer with the same
treatment paradigms. We actually don't have
differential recommendations for patients with colorectal cancer
and liver metastases compared to patients with colorectal cancer and
peritoneal metastases. And the treatment guidelines
and algorithms are always based on biomarker selection and systemic
therapies without actually differentiating between this.
In fact, even in the staging guidelines, it's only been over the past five
to eight years that we're even recognizing the fact that peritoneal
metastases is
site-specific, and therefore, it actually has a higher
TNM staging now, at least in the colorectal cancer space.
This has not yet been recognized in the gastric cancer space.
While we don't have systemic therapy recommendations that
are different for
site-specific metastases, one of the paradigms that has been
developed is this idea that surgeons can go into the peritoneum and
resect as much of peritoneal tissue as possible, and then try and
deliver intraperitoneal chemotherapy in order to try
and eradicate micrometastases. This makes
some obvious sense, but there is a lot of
controversy around this space, and I'm going to spend a little bit of time talking
about the controversy in this space.
So,
as we talk about this, cytoreductive surgery will be referred to as
CRS, and HIPEC essentially means hypothermic
intraperitoneal chemotherapy. And this
essentially means that as the surgeon, and typically the HIPEC is done
after cytoreductive surgery. So the surgeons go in, remove as much peritoneal
tissue as possible, and then use this element to try and deliver
heated chemotherapy into the abdomen, wash everything out, and
eventually the chemotherapy comes off.
So very often, HIPEC is a one-time thing or a one-off thing.
It's not multiple cycles of chemotherapy, how we give systemically.
And there are different agents that are given intraperitoneally for this HIPEC,
and herein lies some of the controversies.There
are other intraperitoneal strategies that are being developed to try and
deliver various systemic therapies into the abdomen.
For colorectal cancer, particularly apart from HIPEC is PIPAC,
which is a pressurized intraperitoneal chemotherapy delivered
through a laparoscope with essentially an
aerosolizer that allows you to deliver high-pressured
chemotherapeutic agents into the abdomen.
But as of today, most of the time, the drugs that are
being delivered into the peritoneum are still chemotherapeutic
agents.
And this was a study that was now published more than 20 years ago.
This is a Dutch group that did a randomized trial
in the era of colorectal cancer systemic therapies that were
very, very weak. Most patients only got
5-fluorouracil and leucovorin as their treatment for metastatic disease.
And in this study,
in about 100 patients, they were randomized to either receive systemic
therapy or to receive what was defined as aggressive
cytoreductive surgery as well as HIPEC.
And in this 50-patient
per arm study, there was a survival benefit for the patients that
received the HIPEC compared to the ones that didn't.
And this set this entire path down this
space, talking about the fact that
maybe patients with peritoneal metastases should get CRS and HIPEC
compared to just getting chemotherapy alone.
But keep in mind that the comparator arm was very non-standard
chemotherapy that's currently contemporary.
So for about 20 years,
we didn't have any other randomized data to support
CRS and HIPEC until about five years ago now, the PRODIGE
07 study was published. This was a much larger
randomized trial across France with multiple different
groups participating in it. And this had more than
250 patients, where the question that was asked very specifically
was not whether cytoreductive surgery was meaningful, but whether
HIPEC was meaningful. So in this study, all patients actually got
cytoreductive surgery but were randomized to then receive HIPEC.
And as you can see here, that the HIPEC actually had no survival benefit,
with both the arms actually having very similar survival.
And this set the entire field into chaos because
now came questions of whether delivering intraperitoneal chemotherapy, at least in
a one-time setting with HIPEC, was meaningful.
Keep in mind that the HIPEC was actually using a drug called oxaliplatin, and
there are some criticisms around this, and this has now been trying
to be studied in different ways. After this, there were
multiple other trials that were also reporting with negative
data. The COLO-PEC trial actually looked at doing adjuvant HIPEC
after surgery, trying to prevent colorectal peritoneal
metastases, and again, we can see there was no survival benefit for doing
HIPEC after primary tumor resections.
Similarly, the French group had another study called PROFYLO-CHIP,
where they were trying to do
prevention of
recurrence of peritoneal metastases after the original resection,
and even in this study, there was no survival benefit for doing the second-look
HIPEC.
More recently, we saw data from the HIPEC-T4 study from the Spanish group,
where patients who were at high risk of having peritoneal metastases,
typically T4 primary tumors,
were then randomized to receive HIPEC.
And the trial had an unusual primary endpoint
of local regional control rate, where the HIPEC showed
an improvement of local control, and this
was actually published a couple of years ago now.
But very recently, just a couple of months ago, they published the
overall survival data, and actually, there was completely no benefit for
overall survival, which means that while some peritoneal disease was being
controlled, the patients were not living longer with the delivery of the
HIPEC.
And also, just last year, we saw the data from the CAIRO6 trial, where,
again,
a relatively unusual way of designing the study where both
arms actually got HIPEC, but then one arm also got systemic therapy,
which is typically not the way we treat our patients with metastatic disease.
And this study actually showed there's no benefit of the systemic chemotherapy,
although this has multiple criticisms to it and has not been
considered
practice-changing at this point in time.
So as of today, the current treatment algorithms and paradigms--
Whoops, that's not good.
So as you can see, after the first
Dutch study in 2003, which was positive, there have been multiple negative trials
for HIPEC. And as of today, the guidelines actually
seem to suggest that there may be a role for cytoreductive surgery and systemic
therapy for patients with peritoneal metastases, but the role of HIPEC is
still being questioned, and at least oxaliplatin-based HIPEC has been
recommended as not to be added after cytoreductive surgery.
And so the patients who do undergo cytoreductive surgery
often now get mitomycin-based chemotherapy if
HIPEC is being delivered, but the guidelines are quite weak for these
recommendations. And it is because of this, there's a lot of nihilism that's
set into place in this peritoneal metastases realm.
And
those of us in the translation space are hoping to shift this by trying to
understand the biology of colorectal peritoneal metastases.
And so over the next few slides, we'll talk a little bit about what we are trying
to do to differentiate out are
all colorectal peritoneal metastases the same?
Should we be doing something different for some of these
patients?And so Dr. Ra spoke
about the TCGA, which is the usual molecular classifier for
most tumor types. But in colorectal cancer, we actually use the consensus molecular
classification that divides out colorectal cancers
into four different subgroups. The subgroup of interest to us is going to
be CMS four, which usually has a high rate of copy number
aberrations, stromal infiltration, TGF-beta activation,
angiogenesis, and typically has a poorer prognosis.
And the reason we use the consensus molecular classification is because compared
to the TCGA in colorectal cancer, they actually had multiple groups with
fairly large numbers of samples that
did primary tumor classifications to come up with this.
And the CMS four
subgroup, as we said, has actually a higher
presence of mesenchymal subtype and cancer stem cells with higher
rates of EMT activation, TGF-beta activation, and matrix
remodeling, as well as angiogenesis that are upregulated in
this subgroup.
We do know that the colorectal peritoneal metastasis patients do have
an enrichment for the CMS four subgroup.
This was an early study that
differentiated out primary tumors and peritoneal tumors, and we can see
that there is a higher number of CMS four subgroup peritoneal tumors.
But one of the bigger papers that has been done is this study that was
published by a Dutch group about three or four years ago now,
where they did multi-omic profiling for about 50
colorectal peritoneal metastases with a few primary tumors
that were paired. And you can see, again, they showed the same thing where
the peritoneal tumors actually had a higher rate of CMS four compared to the
primary tumors. And the ones that were of CMS four actually had a
poorer prognosis compared to the CMS one,
two, or three subtypes.
What they did go on to do then is to look at within the CMS four to come up with
multiple subgroups within CMS four.
And in this study, at least three different CMS
four subgroups were identified with differential
expressions of
RAS mutations as well as TP53. They actually had
differential behavior. They were labeled as
RAS mutated mucinous or
inflamed subgroups over here. And you can see that the tumor
microenvironment compositions for these three different subgroups were
actually different
within the CMS four itself.
And other groups have actually compared colorectal liver metastases
compared to peritoneal metastases and again, you can see
that the liver metastases actually don't have the CMS four as
high compared to the peritoneal metastases.
Again, reiterating this point of organotropism, and it is very likely
that the gene expression programs that are being adopted by primary tumors
will guide the organotropism to the metastatic sites.
And the ones that have the CMS four subtype actually have an
organotropism to the peritoneum.
The tumors that, again, reflected these actually had a poorer prognosis
with the CMS four subtype.
We'll talk a little bit about a paper that we published last year where this
was probably one of the largest multi-omic profiling of colorectal
peritoneal metastases to date in about 120 patients and about
200 over samples with about 30 to 40 paired primary
tumors and peritoneal metastases.
We laid out the landscape for these tumors.
What you can see quite consistently is actually the
genomic landscapes between primary tumors and peritoneal metastases are
actually very similar. There is very little differential genomic
expressions that you can see between primary tumors, kind of reflecting
what we know from the TCGA and CMS classification.
The most common mutations that we were seeing in peritoneal metastases were
TP53, APC, as well as KRAS.
And this is not just our group. Even the Dutch group study showed the same thing.
If you look at transcriptional expression between primary tumors and
peritoneal metastases, you can see clear clustering between the primary
tumors. For example, you can see that the primary tumor and peritoneal metastases
of 39 were quite closely clustered here.
Forty-seven was quite closely clustered here.
But this is actually different if you look at liver metastases, where the liver
metastases actually clustered out very separately compared to the primary
tumors. In terms of retention of or class switching between primary
tumors and peritoneal metastases, it was a very retained, conserved CMS four
that was present in the peritoneal metastases.
But you can see a lot of class switching that's occurring in the liver metastases
space, kind of reflecting this idea that
the seeding that's occurring for peritoneal metastases is more
likely to be polyclonal compared to the seeding that's occurring with liver
metastases that's more likely to be subclonal.
And that's kind of what's alluded here.
Again, multiple groups were showing the same thing, that the seeding for
colorectal cancer tends to be polyclonal.
If you look at this, you can see where they did
single nuclei, single-cell sequencing for a very small subgroup of patients, but
there was very conserved
copy number aberrations that were seen when comparing primary tumors
and peritoneal metastases. But there was quite a lot of clonal heterogeneity when
primary tumors are compared to liver metastases, seeming to suggest what they
were
proposing here, that there is subtype switching and
decreasing of the heterogeneity with a different microenvironment for
liver metastases compared to a conserved
microenvironment and heterogeneity compared to primary tumors
with peritoneal metastases. This might have therapeutic implications because
the way we think about organ-specific treatment paradigms will
actually need to think about this idea that your peritoneal tumors are going to be
polyclonal, and therefore you may not be able to have a specific targeted
therapy paradigm that's going to work for peritoneal metastases
compared to liver metastases, for
example.In
our study here, we also did spatial profiling looking at both
transcriptomic as well as tumor microenvironment heterogeneity.
And while the genomic changes that were previously
reported were very conserved, we were now noticing differential
transcriptomic and microenvironmental heterogeneity, especially if you go down to
the more sophisticated spatial profiling platforms, which were
only
our group were the ones that showed this first.
Where you actually see differential
distributions of CD163 macrophages as well as
CD68 macrophages between primary tumors
and peritoneal metastases, seeming to suggest that from the seed and soil
hypothesis, that once the tumors actually end up in the peritoneum, there is
some remodeling of the peritoneal microenvironment to
allow for this
metastatic growth after the metastatic process has
completed.
And again, this is not just our group. We have other groups also.
This is another study with a small number of liver metastases and peritoneal
metastases, again, comparing the
microenvironmental landscapes and showing that there is clear tumor
microenvironmental differences between colorectal liver
metastases and peritoneal metastases.
In the last few minutes, I'm just going to switch to what we could do about this
heterogeneity. This was a study that we published just a couple
of weeks ago,
where we took from public
databases, multiple cell lines that were classified by CMS
subtypes. And you can see, we looked at the different chemotherapeutic
agents that are being used for HIPEC at this point of time, and that
there is a difference in the way the responses are occurring to these
different chemotherapeutic agents, that is Mitomycin C or Oxaliplatin,
in the CMS four compared to the other CMS groups.
Again, suggesting that maybe rather than calling the entire process
of intraperitoneal chemotherapeutics as
something that's not going to work, we may need to parse out what are the agents
that we're using for these different tumor types as we're treating
them with these intraperitoneal strategies.
And we are also trying to develop different stromal or TME targeting
strategies, which may be better than delivering chemotherapy into the peritoneum.
For example,
in the Dutch group's paper, they actually studied this molecule called
moesin, which essentially works as a
cross-linker between-- It's a transmembrane protein that works as a
cross-linker and was upregulated in their study.
And in this
proof of principle experiment, they show that
targeting moesin may actually have peritoneal responses and could be
a therapeutic strategy. I don't think this is necessarily the
best target, but just this proof of principle that targeting stromal
or microenvironmental components of the peritoneum may be a
therapeutic strategy in the future.
And similarly, in our study, we saw upregulation of
serpin one or PAI-1, which is actually a fibrinolysis
enzyme. And in this study, again, we developed a monoclonal
antibody to try and target PAI-1 as a proof of principle of therapeutic
strategies against peritoneal metastases.
And so in summary, we know that cytoreductive surgery still remains an important
component of the management of colorectal peritoneal metastases, but the choice of
HIPEC, the role of HIPEC, and what agents are used is very disputed at
this point of time.
Colorectal peritoneal metastases is enriched for the CMS subtype, which is
molecularly distinct, and that while there are genomic drivers that are
conserved, that we do see transcriptional and microenvironmental reprogramming that
occurs in peritoneal metastases and
therapeutic resistance.
We should be incorporating this heterogeneity in what
we're thinking about as the next steps of clinical paradigms, and that these
molecularly guided strategies are probably going to be the way forward for these
patients. And with that, I'm going to end my talk. Thank you very much.
Thank you so much, Dr. Sundar. Now it's open for the
questions and the comments. Whoever have a question, please come to the
microphone. And we don't have the
questions from the audience online.
Please, if you have something online, you can give that at the Q&A.
Yes, please. Thank you.
Hello. Matt Leventhal, Boston.
Great talk. And I couldn't help but notice when you were showing the
allele-specific copy number profiles of the peritoneal
mets,
it seemed like the X chromosome was completely lighting up in the copy
number profiles as being amplified.
And did you resolve that allele specific with respect
to each copy of the X chromosome? Or if it is being amplified, what do you
think that X chromosome amplification's doing?
You're talking with the X chromosome amplification?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, in the copy number profile.
I don't have an answer to you because I think that's from the Dutch study, and I
don't think we actually looked at that.
From our whole exome sequencing, I don't think we saw X chromosome amplification,
so I may have to dig back. But it's a good question.
We probably have to dig that out. Their data are publicly available, so it's not
hard to just fish them out and take a deeper look into that.
Sounds great. Thank you.
I have a question about the intraperitoneal treatment.
So until now, most of the cytotoxic treatment is not working well,
and we know now we have some targets specific to the peritoneal.
So in that case, do you think it will work
not only for the systemic, but in the intraperitoneal approach
is more efficacious to deliver those agents?
Right. I think this is a great question.
One of the things that's very hard to
try and comprehend here isThe problem is
that very often cytoreductive surgery and HIPEC kind of go
hand in hand.
Ah, yeah.
There are very few surgeons who are doing cytoreductive surgery without the HIPEC.
Mm-hmm.
And I will say that especially for patients where the peritoneal
disease volume is quite low-
Mm-hmm
... the cytoreductive surgery is actually a very important component.
This is almost like your curative intent surgery that you're doing liver resections
or you're doing lung resections. I would strongly think of the
patients who can get the cytoreductive surgery component as being important.
Okay.
Whether the HIPEC goes in after that is the part that's controversial.
That's what PRODIGE 7 kind of questioned is, do we need the HIPEC?
Can we just do cytoreductive surgery?
Because if you look at the overall survival data from PRODIGE 7, patients with
peritoneal disease were having survival more than three years, which we are not
seeing with systemic therapies.
Yeah.
But whether we need to give our systemic therapies
intraperitoneally, or can we just get better systemic therapies to
circumvent-
Mm-hmm
... the CRS? I think that question has not been answered, and I think if we have
strong systemic therapies, we may not need to give them intraperitoneally.
But that shouldn't remove this idea that we shouldn't be sending our patients to
get the CRS, because that still remains a curative intent thing.
I think if we just give systemic therapies to these patients with peritoneal
disease, they'll still die from the disease unless the surgeons go in and take it
out-
Right
... which is what is curing these patients.
And we're seeing the same thing in gastric cancer as well, where if you have good
responses, we're sending them for conversion surgeries to get the primary tumor
out. That surgical thing to have cure is still quite important, I think, in this
space.
Right.
So, yeah.
Thank you. Yes, please.
Thank you for your presentation. As I'm wondering about
as you're talking about this, what kind of molecular subtype?
How can we define what molecular subtype in clinic for diagnosis?
Yeah, great question. I was actually going to ask Dr.
Ra the same question, is one of the things we
struggle with peritoneal disease is that access to the peritoneal
tissue itself has been pretty challenging.
Mm-hmm.
You can only get peritoneal tissue by doing a diagnostic lap-
Yeah
... which is only now picking up pace, and more surgeons and more groups are
like, "Okay, if we think we have peritoneal disease, let's get the surgeons to go
in, put a camera in and take a look, see if there's peritoneal disease, get
bites off the peritoneal tissue so we can study it." That's one thing that
needs to increase so we get enough tissue to study compared to older
studies that have mostly focused on just isolating cells from
malignant ascites, which may have a different profile to the peritoneal
disease. That's one question. The separate thing that not been
teased out is this difference between synchronous peritoneal metastases and
metachronous peritoneal metastases because differentiating out
synchronous and metachronous to then develop adjuvant
strategies to prevent the metachronous.
Because adjuvant strategies actually have to happen from the metachronous
samples to understand what's leading to metachronous peritoneal metastases,
and that also is very challenging from a clinical sample
collection perspective. Before we start profiling them to understand
them to get to therapeutic targets.
So there's actually a lot of space and work to do in this place because
even just the intelligent sample collection of things to try and
figure out what's happening to then start developing strategies is
still a work in progress. So yeah.
I have one more quick question. As you are working on the gastric
and the colorectal together, and also you have some experience of those
molecular profiling of those two different tumors, do you see
or can you comment on the similar and the differences between
gastric and the colorectal cancer peritoneal mets?
Yeah. So this is very controversial because-
Mm-hmm
... when this idea was purported
a few years ago, everyone rejected this idea saying that this seed and
soil theory-
Mm-hmm
... and the colorectal seed is going to be different from the gastric seed.
How can this work? But I also feel that, and we're going to hear from Dr.
Garcia after this, that
a lot of people who have this thought actually are comparing ovarian cancer with
colorectal cancer and gastric cancer.
And therein, I think there's going to be huge differences because ovarian cancers
are very systemic therapy sensitive, so the peritoneal
metastases in ovarian cancer behave differently from GI cancers.
Mm-hmm.
But if you
just look at the gene expression programs that are upregulated in diffuse subtype
of gastric cancer or
what we call as genomically stable gastric cancer, we see the same stuff.
We see TGF beta, we see stromal infiltration, we see EMT, which is
exactly what you're seeing in the CMS for-
I see
... rectal peritoneal metastases.
So I think there's definitely some conserved programs that is leading to
GI cancer peritoneal metastases, but that may actually be different from ovarian
cancer peritoneal metastases. So that's a good segue to the next talk, actually.
Great answer. Thank you so much. Let's thank Dr.
Raghav Sundar . Okay. And then we'll move to the next speaker.
As you heard, we are most excited to see
the different tumor area that the
peritoneal mets. So Dr.
Ignacio Vazquez Garcia, and he will give us the
talk, Mutational Signatures and Cellular Phenotypes in Ovarian Peritoneal
Metastasis.
Let's welcome Dr. Garcia .
So thank you to the organizers for this fantastic opportunity to share some of our
work and to Dr. Ra and Dr. Sundar.
And today I will tell you a little bit about some of our work
on ovarian peritoneal metastasis, in particular looking at the interplay
between mutational processes and cellular phenotypes in this disease.
So, no disclosures to declare.
So as you've heard already from Dr.
Sundar, high-grade serous ovarian cancer is in some ways an archetypal
disease that presents with
peritoneal metastases.
And
among other, just as a reminder, some other key features in this disease
in terms of the disease etiology is that
the majority of these tumors are P53 deficient, and a large number of them
also present with homologous recombination repair defects.
And at the time of diagnosis, there tends to be
metastatic dissemination into the peritoneal cavity,
and thisSort of gives a lot of room because of the
long latency of the disease for
sort of clonal diversification and diverse tumor immune interaction to
happen within the cavity.
And so there's also a major need for
new therapeutic strategies. There have been attempts to
try immune checkpoint blockade that have not worked well, and
these patients are primarily treated with carboplatin paclitaxel, and some of them,
if they're HR deficient, get PARP inhibitors, but there's still a major unmet
clinical need. There have been studies that have looked previously using bulk
sequencing approaches at the heterogeneity of the
peritoneal cavity that have found quite a large diversity
of clones.
And
this is something that we're now trying to study in detail using single-cell
technologies.
Before I get to that,
I just want to give you a little bit more detail as to what the interplay is
between these underlying mutational processes in ovarian cancer
and
how they may impact cell states within these tumors.
So,
in ovarian cancer, there is a major subgroup here on the left
of around 50% or so of cases that are HR deficient.
What I'm showing you here are around 170 or so
whole genome sequences from high-grade serous ovarian cancer on the x-axis.
On the y-axis are genomic features,
both point mutations or SNVs and structural variants
that we can use to try to stratify these patients into HR deficient and proficient.
One thing you can see is that there is a superset of patients that are HR deficient
that are not necessarily BRCA mutant, annotated here on the top.
And so this is a genomic assay that can be useful in order to identify what
patients may be responsive to PARP inhibitors.
There's a number of associated genomic features that define
also subtypes of the disease. In particular, the BRCA1 tumors, they tend to present
with
small and medium-sized tandem duplications, whereas
what we call the HRD-del versus HRD-dup
tumors, the HRD-del tend to be the BRCA2-like tumors, and they tend to have these
patterns of interstitial deletions.
By contrast, there's also a major group of HR-proficient tumors that include
what we refer to as the FBI or fold-back inversion tumors, because they tend to
have this sort of typical pattern in their genomes that facilitates the
amplification of oncogenes like cyclin E1.
There are other rarer subtypes, for example,
CDK12 loss-of-function
mutants that tend to have very poor prognosis.
And indeed, when you look across using these
genomic signatures for patient stratification, you can see that,
in general, the HR deficient patients tend to do better than the HR proficient
patients.
In addition to that, there was also some previous work that had looked
at bulk profiling, transcriptomic profiling of these tumors that
had found
hints that there may be distinct immune profiles between the HR deficient
and proficient tumors. But this ultimately was confounded by the
underlying composition, immune and stromal composition of those tumors.
And so
we wanted to address these questions using single-cell technologies, and in
particular today, I'd like to sort of tell you two
short stories. First one is primarily looking at the impact that these
early mutational processes, such as the HR deficiency,
have on the cell states in these tumors,
and how those facilitate peritoneal metastases.
So first, so this is a study that I did when I was in New
York doing my postdoc in the lab of Dr.
Sourabh Shah, and it was a close collaboration with
Gyn oncologist, Dimitrios Samarian, now at Mount Sinai.
And I co-led this project with Florian Ulitz.
And we initiated a study in early
2019, prospective collection of newly diagnosed high-grade serous
ovarian cancer patients.
So as a reminder, these patients either undergo primary debulking
surgeries or laparoscopic biopsies,
or laparoscopies followed by
neoadjuvant chemo and then interval debulking.
So there is an opportunity to sample peritoneal disease,
particularly in the primary debulking setting, untreated disease.
And indeed, we took that opportunity to collect both primary tumor
samples as well as any metastasis from the peritoneal cavity
as well as ascites. And we did a multimodal profiling
effort that included both single-cell RNA
sequencing directly from fresh tissue, as well as single-cell whole genome
sequencing that I'll tell you about in the second part of the talk, as well
as spatial multimodal profiling and also
bulk genome sequencing to stratify the patients into HR deficient and proficient.
So using the single-cell transcriptomic profiling,
what we first tried to describe was the presence of different major cell
types within the microenvironment.
And here what I'm showing you is, this is a cohort of around
41 patients.
You can see that we can identify all the major
immune stromal cell types as well as the cancer cells.
And one thing that
stood out immediately is that the individual patients here colored
individually on the left-hand side UMAP, they tend to cluster by
themselves. This is something that we've studied in quite a lot of
depth that tends to result from the major chromosomal
aberrations and copy number alterations that these tumors have that
impact the gene expression profiles because of dosage effects
in these tumor cells.
And as I mentioned, we did multi-site profiling that included both the
primary and metastatic sites, as well as ascites,
and I'll be telling you a little bit about the differences between those.
So firstly, we focused on the cancer cell states, and
we tried to learnWhat may be
unique cell states that are present across multiple
patients as a way of extending what's
known in terms of consensus molecular subtypes that have also been developed in
ovarian cancer,
based on bulk studies by TCGA and others.
And we identified several unique clusters,
in particular for the malignant lineage.
We identified several sets of clusters that were associated both with the
underlying HR deficiency and the site heterogeneity.
So in particular, this cluster three tends to be very prevalent in the HR deficient
tumors.
And also when we compared the adnexal, non-adnexal and
ascites samples, we also observed that tumor cells found in
ascites tend to have very distinct transcriptional profiles.
So homing in on the differences between the different genomic subtypes and
the
adnexal and peritoneal metastases, we found that in
the HR deficient tumors, there tends to be
upregulation of type one interferon signaling and JAK STAT
signaling, and a lot of different components of the
antigen presentation machinery, which by contrast,
don't seem to be expressed in the HR proficient so-called
FBI tumors, which seem to express
immunosuppressive programs like TGF beta.
So turning to the immune compartment,
we focused on trying to characterize all the major CD4,
CD8 T cells and NK cell phenotypes.
And we identified that there's subsets of
dysfunctional T cells that tend to be more frequently found in
both the adnexal and peritoneal metastases, especially in the HR deficient
tumors. So this suggested to us that there may have been
sort of earlier
T cell killing activity that eventually resulted in a blunted immune response, and
so we wanted to understand whether this had resulted in the acquisition of certain
mechanisms of immune escape. And so we focused in particular
on a mechanism
which is often acquired by cancer cells by either
down-regulating or
losing the genomic HLA locus,
and thus diminishing the capacity for the cancer cell to present new
antigens. Which then
as a result can no longer be recognized, and so then act as an immune
resistance mechanism.
So building on quite a lot of work by many groups, including Charlie
Swanton's group, Nikki McCray Hanhan's group, and others, we extended some of these
techniques to be applicable to single cell data and to infer
subclonal as well as clonal HLA loss by focusing on the
6p locus where the HLA class one genes sit.
And so what we did here is we took the fact that we had
bulk genome sequencing from blood as well as matched tumor single cell
RNA seq, and tried to infer 6p
loss based on the B allele frequency for germline SNPs in the tumor
compared to the non-malignant cell types.
And that then allows us to map
the presence of 6p loss in individual cells and to map that to
transcriptional clusters.
Once we do that, we can then compare the prevalence of
these events in different genomic subtypes.
And we found excuse me, that this is
more common early in the BRCA1-like HRD-DUPE tumors,
which seem to often have clonal 6p LOH by
comparison in the foldback inversion HR proficient tumors, and
as well as the BRCA2 HRD-DEL tumors, this seems to be most
often subclonal. This is something that we validated through targeted sequencing by
MSK Impact.
And then we tried to then understand whether this was associated
with specific transcriptional programs in those cancer cells.
And we identified that indeed, those cells that lose the
6p locus tend to more frequently upregulate JAK STAT
signaling. And then we then asked whether
these cancer cells that had lost the HLA locus
were in specific microenvironments that were more replete
with T cells that perhaps were naive or
dysfunctional. And indeed, we saw that there was much more T-cell dysfunction, as
we had seen in the HR deficient tumors,
that were also more prevalent in those tumors that had
lost 6p clonally.
Just to sum up this part of the talk, we did then a
validation in terms of the specific
tumor immune interactions that we observe in these different genomic subtypes using
the Aquaria Bio Vector platforms, which is a seven-color assay that we
use to study PD-1, PD-L1 interactions.
And here I'm showing you three exemplars of HR deficient
tumors along the top, and at the bottom here, HR proficient tumor.
And you can see highlighted here interactions between the
different sets of CD8 T cell phenotypes and cancer cells.
And you can see in general that there's a higher prevalence of PD-1, PD-L1
interactions happening in
particular in the BRCA1-like tumors, and especially the
HR proficient tumors seem to be mostly immune inert, and there are
very few of these interactions happening.
We tried to quantify this at scale across the cohort
in more than 1,000 fields of view by looking at
proximal interactions based on the radial distance of a
focal cell which is PD-L1 expressing cancer cell
and different flavors of CD8 T cell phenotypes.
And we saw that indeed in the HR, the DUPE, the BRCA1-like
tumors, there are many more proximal interactions between
the PD-L1 positive cancer cells and T cells.
So now turning to the second part of the talk, and I'll try to move
quickly.
I've told you about a process that ultimately is happening early.
So HR deficiency happens clonally.
Often these patients inactivate BRCA1 or
BRCA2.
And there's a divergence that happens early between the HR deficient and
proficient tumors.We then wanted to ask whether there are also other
ongoing recent forms of genome instability that may have
an interplay with these different cell states.
And in order to do that, we collaborated with the lab of Sam
Vakhm and Andrew McPherson, and this was a project led together with Matt
Myers and Doaa Al Rawi.
And we leveraged a technology that had been originally developed
by Saurabh when he was over in Vancouver before he moved
to MSK, and with a lab of Sama Paricio for doing single cell
whole genome sequencing. So I won't go too much into the details, but this allows
us to do
profiling of hundreds of thousands of cancer cells for each individual
tumor, and then to resolve copy number profiles for
individual cells. So you can see one such cell down here.
In red are gains, and in blue are losses, and gray
are deployed regions. And we can also use this technology to detect
haplotype-specific copy numbers.
So these are balanced regions of the genome as well as regions that have copy
neutral OH, like chromosome 13 or 17, which are commonly lost in
these tumors.
And so we applied this technology at scale across more than
40 patients that um, are thus overlapping with the ones that I presented in the
first part of the talk.
And here what you can see is a quantification of the
ploidy of all of these cells across the cohort.
So,
along the y-axis is the cell ploidy.
Each dot is a cell, and they're colored by the number of genome doubling events.
So what you can readily see is that on the right-hand side, there are a lot of
tumors that have these orange and red cells.
Those are cells that are tetraploid or higher ploidy.
And on the left-hand side, there's many tumors that still have a dominant diploid
population and a few tetraploid cells.
Now, in this disease, in previous studies,
by bulk sequencing, around 60% of these tumors have been described as being genome
doubled. What we're seeing is actually that 100% of tumors have genome doubled
cells. And so,
this was really a
key observation for us because we wanted to understand
how do we try to reason about this sort of ongoing process that's present in all
the tumors at different degrees.
So homing in on
one of these cases,
here there's a couple of things that I'd like to highlight.
First of all, that a lot of these states can coexist within a tumor.
So you can see that there are cells that are baseline diploid
that occur in the primary site, which here is the right adnexa.
And
here those cells are baseline diploid. You can see that in gray.
This is a total copy number on the left-hand side.
And then there is a derived genome double cell, as
well as
another subsequent clone that acquires another genome doubling event.
All of those clones are actually present across the entire peritoneal cavity
and
the left adnexa, which is another metastatic site in this particular tumor.
You can see that these states coexist, and so therefore, I think we need to be
thinking about how this process is potentially diversifying these tumors across the
peritoneal cavity.
Zooming out again,
one other aspect that we've tried to quantify is perhaps not just the
clonal structure of the specific sub clones, but rather the fact that there are
cell-specific differences in genotype
that are really critical. And we try to quantify these at
scale, but by comparing here one example of a tumor that's baseline
diploid and one that's baseline tetraploid.
And one thing that you can see straight away is that in the baseline tetraploid
tumors, there's a lot of these individual stripes.
Those correspond to cell-specific aneuploidies gains or
losses that are just found in a single cell.
And those result typically under
processes like chromosome missegregation, where you can have, for example, a
lagging chromosome that ends up just in one of the two daughter cells, which can
result in a gain or a loss. And so this then allowed us to
quantify such rates at scale by distinguishing the ancestral
copy number state from the cell-specific aneuploidies.
Once we do that, we can then ask, okay, is this mostly driven by the
underlying genome doubling or the HR deficiency?
And we can see that by and large, there's these different classes of events
from arm level changes, whole chromosome changes, segmental aneuploidies are
driven by genome doubling.
And indeed, when we try to explain this by either the HR deficiency or the genome
doubling, we see that most of this variation is driven by the genome doubling
itself.
One
aspect of this ongoing chromosomal instability that has drawn a lot of attention in
recent years is the fact that these may also result in immune
activation through c-gastric signaling.
So, and we took that also as an opportunity to validate the fact that we
are observing these ongoing chromosome segregation through single cell genomics to
validate it by imaging. To do this, what we did is we used
a
multiplex immunofluorescence assay where we imaged
both primary metastatic sites for cGAS, which is
a marker for double-stranded cytosolic
DNA,
which can be present when you often get one of these
desegregated chromosomes that through mitosis can end up becoming encapsulated
in these structures called micronuclei that often they tend to
have fairly weak nuclear envelopes, and when they rupture, they release the
double-stranded DNA into the cytosol.
So we developed a deep learning approach to detect these cGAS
positive punctate objects that you can see here in this
pseudocolor image,
that shows PanCK for epithelial cells, DAPI as a
marker for primary nuclei, and cGAS as a marker for ruptured micronuclei.
And so using this method, we can segment these micronuclei at scale and then
calculate rates of these processes.
And we see that indeed this is sort of a very common,
ongoing process that may have resulted in the past few cell divisions of
these cancer cells.
This is something that we then have tried to explore further in terms of the
impact that
the presence of these micronuclei and these missegregated chromosomes may be having
on cGAS DNA activation.And one fairly striking
finding that we saw is that rather than
increased micronucleus rupture resulting in higher
STING activation, which can result in downstream type I interferon signaling,
et cetera, we actually saw a very strong anti-correlation that was
context-dependent, which depended on the presence or absence of genome
doubling. So once the cells become genome doubled, they have such high levels of
instability that they need to down-regulate cGAS-STING signaling as a
prerequisite for them to be able to expand.
Just to finish up, I want to highlight the fact that
beyond this, we're now starting to sample these
cancers by single cell whole genome sequencing also comprehensively
across the entire peritoneal cavity.
We've done this already to a large extent with single cell RNA-seq, but we're
now also doing it with single cell whole genome sequencing, which allows us to then
map these routes of metastatic dissemination in detail.
And this will allow us to ask questions, for example, around
how these different events may be diversifying the clone in the primary site, which
you can see here in this particular tumor left adnexa,
and whether there's ongoing diversification happening from additional
events in the metastatic,
in the peritoneal cavity. So in all these other sites that you can see
intermixed in this heat map that seem to be diversifying
after another genome doubling event.
Okay, so with that, just to sum up, I've told you that we're
starting to build this sort of
new model for keratotypic diversification and the impact
that that has on immunoreactivity for these tumor types.
That there's this sort of two axes of
variation of the underlying mutational processes and the anatomic site
that are really critical
to
understand the heterogeneity of the disease.
In particular, we've seen that there's a major interplay with the
underlying HR deficiency and mechanisms of immune escape that
facilitate peritoneal metastases.
I've also told you that beyond the DNA repair deficiency, there's a key
interplay with
more
recent processes that are going on in the tumors, such as chromosome segregation,
genome doubling, and that occur at elevated rates and facilitate clonal
diversification. So, I would also invite you to read up on
this nice summary of some of our work that suggests some of the
potential opportunities to try to target certain
vulnerabilities in these two genomic subtypes, in particular,
strategies to go after TGF-beta in the HR proficient and other
immunotherapy targets in the HR deficient.
Just to thank my lab and my colleagues at MSK and collaborators
also at MGH and we're continuing some of this work in collaboration with Sam
Klempner, Steve Bloom, and other colleagues,
the funders, and also just to highlight, an undergrad in my lab
who'll be giving a poster tomorrow. So thank you all for listening.
Thank you so much. It's a great talk.
It's open for the questions and comments.
So while we are waiting for the... Do you want something to start?
Yeah, I think ovarian cancer is really
dependent on that HRD versus non-HRD.
So you mentioned that the genome doubling low and high,
is it related to that HRD status or it's an independent
system related to STING or other pathway
activation?
Yeah, that's a great point. So we see that in the BRCA1
tumors, they tend to be mostly baseline deployed with a few low prevalence
genome doubled clones. We don't know whether that's because of
the negative selection of cells that acquire more double-strand
breaks that can't cope with those, if they're BRCA deficient or it's
something else, that's something that we would have to test functionally, but we do
see that difference. The numbers are small, but there is a signal there.
Thank you. Please.
Have you looked at -- a really great study.
Have you looked at the recurrent lesions after chemotherapy and
compare them with primary and see like tumor evolution, which clones survive
chemo and immune composition?
Yeah, we have done some of that in another study.
We haven't done as comprehensive profiling of the interval debulking
samples yet. They tend to be fairly difficult to process with a lot of necrosis
and so on. But we do see expansion of genome doubled clones
during and after chemo. We've studied that, not just from the
biopsies themselves, but also through cell-free DNA sequencing in another study
where we've tracked these clones in a clone specific manner, through
a patient specific panel approach in cell-free DNA.
And you do see that usually the genome double clones tend to be the ones that
expand.
Yeah, because there's like parsing these samples you can look at,
the recurrent patients, which is like in a lot of tissue and may
reflect the drug-resistant clone.
Yeah.
Definitely. I think
one opportunity will be to try to understand
how this sort of network of clones that are going back and
forth through the peritoneal cavity, how that occurs.
I think sampling ascites will be a really good strategy to do that because
we'd still be able to access the cancer cells directly.
So if there's any new clones that are arising when patients relapse, that may be
something that we can measure directly.
Thank you.
Please.
Ignacio, great talk.
So we've talked a lot of primary tumor, peritoneal tumor comparisons for
GI cancers. Are you seeing retention
or subclonal sort of
mechanisms between in ovarian cancer?
Is there class switch between HRD, those sort of things comparing primary and
metastasis?
Mm-hmm.
What is the landscape like for ovarian cancers?
Yeah.
So I think
some of the major differences are,
I would say theAdnexal
tumors tend to be immune privileged for the most part.
In terms of overall immune infiltration characterized by H&E, we've
done the multiplex IF, single cell RNASeq, there's a very consistent signal across
the board that they are less T cell infiltrated.
In the HR deficient tumors, there's a lot of
T cell dysfunction in the primaries especially.
We also see presence of Tregs across both sites.
And then I think there's also a very strong covariation of
expression of certain myeloid programs that I didn't have time to get
into in HR deficient tumors, especially like expressing CXCL9,
CXCL10, and so on.
Right. But what I mean is
comparing across tumor types is fine, but within the same patient
and the same samples, is
it polyclonal or is it monoclonal
metastasis that's occurring?
Yeah.
So
we don't have a good answer to that, mostly because of sampling.
I think the answer that exists so far
based on bulk sequencing, there was a study that I alluded to at the beginning that
had done the most thorough multi-site sampling with bulk,
that did actually a...
It was a comparative study with colorectal cancer, other multi-site studies that
had been done at the time.
And it described that there was a lot more clonal intermixing by comparison.
So they were using data from
colorectal peritoneal metastasis from Camilia Axarova's lab, and some data from
Shorap's lab, bulk data. And the result that was that in general, there's a lot
more intermixing in ovarian.
Yeah. Great.
Great talk. I had one quick question.
I hadn't realized this before about the class two expression in ovarian cancer
cells. What do you think that that's doing? Is that response to interferon?
Is that interacting with Tregs?
It's an interesting finding that I think only happens in a subset of tumor cells,
and the fact that it's so prevalent in ovarian cancer, I thought was interesting.
Yeah. So we haven't really dissected that.
But I think that's something I'd love to explore a bit further. Yeah.
Sounds good.
Yep. Yes, please. We still have seconds.
Go ahead.
I think if you talk, it will work. It's not?
Okay.
Good morning. I'm Dr. Sihui Yang at NCI Intramural.
So I have a very primitive level of questions here.
So, do you think this peritoneal disease is more
from the macroscopic
invasiveness
of disease, or this tumor cell itself has some biology
to like to go to the peritoneal space?
Well, so in ovarian cancer, I think there's really no immediate barrier
for these early disseminated cells to go, especially to the
omentum.
So I think out of all high-grade serous ovarian cancer
diagnoses, the number of patients that present with omental metastasis is really,
really high. It's,
I think, the
first metastatic site typically.
How that occurs, I think it's still a process that's not fully understood.
I think for that, one of the underlying reasons why we wanted to also
sample the ascites is that we wanted to understand this process of transcoelomic
metastasis better.
I think one unknown there is whether this is mediated by
individual cancer cells that can migrate or whether they are large
clumps of clusters in
the invasive front that are the ones that sort of pioneer the metastatic
dissemination.
Okay. Thank you so much. It's time for wrap up. And thank you, Dr.
Ignatija. And as you heard,
peritoneal metastasis from the...
Do you have a question?
Okay. From GI and the other tumors has a different biology, and still,
we don't know much about that. So, it's not just biology.
Also still, as you heard from colorectal cancer, different
treatment strategies is not working well, and we need a lot to
study, work together, and figure out what's the problem and
what's the way we can move on. And I hope
today's session is giving us a good opportunity to think about
the problem of peritoneal metastasis and the
increasing information from the recent technology.
And I hope you enjoyed it. And I will finish the session,
and thank you all for the Q&A and the great
speakers today. And please enjoy the rest of the
AACR. Thank you.